Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous parle d'une technique très efficace pour la mémoire, je parle bien sûr, évidemment, des flash cards !
Dans une vidéo assez récente j'ai abordé cette technique pour apprendre et je me suis aperçu dans les commentaires que vous ne la connaissiez pas forcément.
Alors on va corriger ça, générique !
[musique du générique]
Tout commence avec Hermann Hebingo, c'est un philosophe allemand, qui un matin s'est réveillé et a fait:
"Dis donc, est-ce que la mémoire et l'apprentissage ne pourraient pas se développer par des méthodes cognitives un petit peu différentes ?"
Et suite à cette brillante question, il est le premier à mettre en place des méthodes expérimentales pour comprendre le fonctionnement de la mémoire.
Et pour ça il fait des tests où il fait apprendre des choses qui n'ont pas forcément de sens, comme des suites de lettres qui ne veulent rien dire.
Et c'est dans les années 1970 que Sébastien Leitner qui lui était un scientifique allemand met au point les cartes mémoires que nous appellerons ensuite les flash cards !
En se basant principalement sur les travaux de ce bon Hermann, oui je dis son prénom qui est plus facile à prononcer que le nom de famille.
Et aussi sur le principe de la répétition espacée.
Le principe est très simple, il faut avoir des cartes ou des fiches cartonnées, ou des petites cartes... où d'un coté on met une question et de l'autre coté on met la réponse.
Et le but c'est de se servir d'un principe dont je vous ai déjà parlé, qui est le fait de repasser fréquemment et régulièrement sur le chemin mental qu'on a créé pour creuser ça,
et le rendre plus profond dans la mémoire.
Le fonctionnement de base c'est le suivant:
vous prenez une boite avec plusieurs compartiments dans la boite, le plus possible d'ailleurs, 7 c'est plutôt pas mal.
Et vous mettez toutes vos cartes mémoires, vos flash cards dans le premier compartiment.
Quand vous allez travailler vos cartes, vous prenez une des cartes dans le premier compartiment, vous lisez la question, vous cherchez la réponse dans votre tête, vous vérifiez.
Si c'est la bonne réponse, vous la mettez dans le compartiment suivant. Si c'est la mauvaise réponse,  vous la remettez dans ce compartiment là pour être sûr de pouvoir y revenir.
Et chaque jour vous faites ça avec les cartes qui se trouvent dans le premier stock, dans le premier compartiment.
Par contre tous les deux jours, vous le faites également avec les cartes qui sont dans le deuxième compartiment.
Tous les trois jours vous le faites également dans celles qui sont dans le troisième compartiment etc...
Jusqu'à 7 compartiments.
Ce qui fait qu'en fonction des choses que vous savez déjà, vous allez les revoir de manière plus ou moins espacées, jusqu'à temps de les mettre dans la mémoire long terme.
Je vous recommande également une boite qui ne sera vu qu'une fois par semaine et une autre qui ne sera vu qu'une fois par mois, et pourquoi pas une boite qui ne sera vu que tous les 6 mois.
C'est-à-dire que celle qui est dans la carte tous les 1 mois, vous la prenez, vous regardez la question, vous trouvez la réponse, vous la mettez sur la boite 6 mois, sinon vous la laissez dans la boite 1 mois.
Pour être sûr de la revoir le mois prochain.
Avec ce système vous pouvez apprendre de nouvelles langues, des formules de maths, des dates historiques, du vocabulaire, des noms de médicaments... tout ce que vous voulez !
Et si vous prenez en compte tous les vecteurs cognitifs vous pouvez construire vos flash cards également avec des dessins, de la couleur...
C'est encore plus efficace !
Moi je m'en suis servi à l'époque où j'avais appris ma première table de rappel.
Je m'étais fait des flash cards, avec d'un côté le dessin et d'un autre côté le nombre ou le chiffre.
Et si vous ne savez pas ce que c'est une table de rappel, regardez dans ma playlist mémoire, j'en ai parlé plusieurs fois cette année.
Je vous recommande de faire les question les plus simples possible avec les réponses les plus simples possible.
Les flash cards ne sont pas faites pour retenir des paragraphes entiers, pleins de mots ou une énumération.
C'est pas facile à dire "énumération".
Chaque carte doit être dédiée à une seule chose, donc vous pouvez simplifier au maximum.
Par exemple si on prend le fameux 1515 Marignan, vous aurez pu mettre "Marignan" d'un coté, et "1515" de l'autre.
Puisque c'est vous qui les construisez, vous même vous savez à quoi ça se réfère.
Evidemment, priorisez l'ordre des cartes par l'ordre d'importance des choses que vous voulez apprendre.
J'ai  trouvé un site qui s'appelle "Studyblue", qui permet de les faire en ligne ou sur son Smartphone.
Il y a une version gratuite et une version payante mais cherchez sur Internet, il doit bien y avoir d'autres sites pour ça.
D’ailleurs si vous connaissez vous même des versions  gratuites sur ça, sur Smartphone ou sur l'ordinateur, pour les faire de manière dématérialisée, n'hésitez pas à nous le dire dans les commentaires, à le partager avec l'ensemble des mentalos.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que vous trouverez ça plus clair concernant cet outil que j'adore utiliser.
Pensez également, avant de partir à vous abonner à la chaîne.
Puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour depuis bientôt 300 jours !
Oui ma petite dame, bientôt 300 jours !
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique du générique de fin]